you know a xiaolin so often savings to
me on our spies you can slap your
[ __ ]
hey I've seen who are you what's your
name I can't remember anything that
happened before two weeks ago I don't
know who I am I don't know where I'm
going
none
you cannot run what you did this you
made yourself however I remember
everything
Jesus Christ that's Jason Bourne why
would he come back now this is still a
clandestine agency now he's seen things
in those things what can you tell me
about tricks Joe there's something
you're not telling me I want it now do
you understand
what else Jason Bourne happened do you
hear me he's still out there we gotta
find this son of a [ __ ] and take him
down
I'm on my own side Nonis realistic way
to end this is to eliminate the threat I
swear to God if I even feel somebody
there is no measure to how fast and how
hard I will bring this fight to your
doorstep
you have no idea what you're into here
now borns gunning for her stack for
revenge spend three years trying to find
out who I am I volunteered because of a
lie
three two
you